salut dans ma dernière vidéo vous vous
souvenez sûrement on a parlé des
opérations des yeux au laser la
chirurgie réfractive et à la fin de
cette vidéo je vous avais dit ceci donc
je vais me faire opérer et je reviens
très bientôt pour vous raconter tout ça
et ben voilà on y va
alors avant de commencer oui vous savez
exactement ce que je vais vous dire
cette vidéo est sponsorisée
cette vidéo est sponsorisée par
nordvpn alors oui vous savez exactement
ce que c'est mais comme moi c'est ma
toute première fois je vais quand même
vous faire le topo nordvpn il y a un
indice dans le nom c'est un VPN un
service de réseau virtuel privé
ça chiffre votre connexion ce serait la
connexion ok mais pourquoi faire
pourquoi faire pour votre sécurité déjà
si vous vous connectez à un wifi public
par exemple et pour vous protéger des
logiciels malveillants et puis ça vous
permet aussi d'avoir accès à des
contenus qui sont d'habitude par
accessibles dans le pays dans lequel
vous êtes genre des contenus étrangers
si vous êtes en France ou vos contenus
habituels si vous êtes à l'étranger etc
etc alors maintenant je vous vois venir
vous allez me dire et comment on fait
pour faire ça je vais vous le dire bien
sûr d'abord évidemment faut s'inscrire
mais attention pas n'importe comment
passer par mon petit lien perso que je
vous mets là et dans la description de
la vidéo ça vous permettra d'avoir une
super offre en plus c'est satisfait ou
remboursé pendant 30 jours ensuite
télécharger l'application si vous voulez
vous servir sur un téléphone ou aller
sur le site si vous êtes sur un ordi
après vous configurez tout ça vous allez
voir c'est hyper simple et puis vous
faites votre petite vie en toute
sécurité et en toute discrétion là moi
par exemple je cherche des documentaires
scientifiques uniquement accessibles
depuis le Japon voilà
donc vous avez tout dans la description
et je vous le remets ici aussi foncez
c'est cadeau ceci étant dit c'est parti
pour l'opération des yeux voilà donc je
vais me faire opérer des yeux au laser
et je vais vous emmener avec moi à
chaque fois comme ça vous verrez bien
toutes les étapes et à chaque fois je
vous expliquerai ce qui se passe pour
que vous compreniez bien là le premier
rendez-vous c'est ce qu'on appelle la
consultation préopératoire c'est à dire
que je vais aller voir le chirurgien qui
potentiellement va peut-être m'opérer et
à la fin de ce cette consultation on
saura si je suis opérable ou pas c'est à
dire si je vais pouvoir me faire opérer
des yeux au laser on y va
moi j'y vais bonjour je suis la voix off
de cette vidéo
oui bon c'est moi en fait c'est la voix
de Julien la voix off c'est une voix qui
guide le spectateur dans les moments
forts d'une intrigue et qui
bon bref bon alors donc là l'ophtalmo il
est en train d'évaluer ma vision il
vérifie si je suis bien presbyte déjà et
à quel point il vérifie si je vois bien
de loin vous comprendrez pourquoi c'est
important tout à l'heure il regarde si
c'est possible de corriger ma vue et si
ma cornée est assez solide pour
supporter l'opération donc il m'a fait
plein d'examens comme ça et puis à la
fin voilà donc vous
êtes je suis opérable donc il m'a
expliqué comment ça allait se passer
mais je vous spoile pas voilà vous avez
vu la Bonne Nouvelle bah je vais pouvoir
me faire opérer j'ai même déjà pris
rendez-vous pour l'intervention voilà
dans mon petit dossier là j'ai des
ordonnances j'ai plein de lectures plein
de trucs à remplir à lire etc on va
faire tout ça ensemble et puis vous
allez m'accompagner jusqu'à l'opération
ok ça commence à devenir un petit peu
concret l'opération approche à grands
pas les trois jours précédents
l'intervention il faut que je me mette
des gouttes dans les yeux donc j'ai les
ordonnances je vais chercher ça à la
pharmacie j'en profite pour prendre les
gouttes qu'il faudra que je mette après
l'intervention allez go
c'est beau mais il fait froid ça me fait
pas un petit peu pleurer les yeux j'ai
les yeux sensibles je sais pas si c'est
une bonne nouvelle
voilà ça y est j'ai tout bon paquet de
médicaments et de gouttes pour les yeux
sauf que j'ai oublié mon dossier à la
pharmacie donc j'ai retourné
j'ai toujours les yeux qui pleurent ok
donc c'est bon j'ai toutes mes gouttes
en gros il y en a pour traiter les yeux
secs pour bien hydrater et il y en a
c'est des gouttes antibiotiques donc je
dois en mettre trois fois par jour les
trois jours qui précèdent l'intervention
donc c'est aujourd'hui que je commence
c'est pas je viens de me faire
extrêmement mal c'est pas pratique de se
mettre des gouttes tout seul sauf si on
a des lentilles auquel cas on est
habitué moi c'est pas mon cas donc je
vais me débrouiller
quelques petits tips pour vous
[Musique]
première chose vous vérifiez la date de
péremption de vos gouttes il faut faire
ça avant d'utiliser n'importe quel
médicament c'est valable pour ça aussi
deuxième chose vous vous lavez les mains
on tripote pas ses yeux avec ces grosses
mains pleines de barres de métro ou
pleine de
pas savoir troisième chose la partie
pratique maintenant pour bien exposer le
cul-de-sac conjonctival la paupière
inférieure on la tire vers le bas
ensuite on penche la tête en arrière on
regarde vers le haut comme ça ça oblige
l'oeil à rester grand ouvert on approche
la pipette ou le flacon de gouttes de
l'oeil mais pas trop près parce qu'il
faut pas toucher et puis ensuite on
appuie délicatement on devrait voir une
petite goutte trembloter et on attend
qu'elle tombe dans l'oeil et si c'est
raté bah on recommence en plein dedans
du premier coup ensuite si vous avez
d'autres gouttes à mettre après il faut
regarder combien de temps il faut
attendre entre les deux il y a certaines
gouttes que vous pouvez enchaîner sans
problème il y en a d'autres il faut
attendre 5 minutes d'autres 10 15
minutes etc pour savoir ça comment on
fait bah c'est pas difficile il suffit
de regarder sur la notice des gouttes
dernière chose très importante une fois
que vous avez mis vos gouttes si c'est
une unidose comme ça et ben une ido
c'est à dire que ça circule une fois
donc après il faut les jeter parce qu'en
fait c'est pas stable le risque c'est
que ça s'infecte et que vous infectiez
vos yeux ce qui n'est pas le but hein
c'est même le but inverse voilà bon bah
l'opération c'est pour demain j'ai bien
respecté toutes les consignes du médecin
avec les gouttes comme comme vous avez
vu donc je suis prêt quoi pour l'instant
je voulais dire je suis obligé de mettre
ça
et j'espère que ça va marcher demain
parce que c'est ma dernière paire de
lunettes j'ai vraiment perdu l'autre
hier donc là c'est ma dernière paire de
lunettes c'est juste des loups pas
après j'en ai plus donc si tout va bien
j'en aurais pas besoin de toute façon
ok bah ça approche de plus en plus
jour de l'intervention faut y aller avec
des lunettes de soleil donc moi j'ai
tout prévu des lunettes de soleil pour
se protéger les yeux en sortant parce
que je vais avoir les yeux a priori un
petit peu sensible et le jour de
l'intervention il faudra juste que je ne
me maquille pas les yeux ce qui n'était
pas prévu en ce qui me concerne et pas
de parfum pas d'after shape etc voilà
tout ça j'imagine c'est ce qui est
marqué sur mon petit sur un mon petit
papier là
j'imagine que c'est pour pas abîmer les
fins irriter les yeux avant le avant
l'opération voilà bah perso je suis prêt
je suis assez
content de pouvoir bientôt me passer de
ça
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être une
bonne idée aussi de faire un petit un
petit point pourquoi j'ai décidé de
faire cette opération bah d'abord pour
la science évidemment pour vous public
non évidemment ça m'intéressait de
documenter la chose et puis je suis pas
en un je suis presbyte ce qui n'a rien à
voir donc oui évidemment j'ai un trouble
de la vision et bah comme je vous ai dit
voilà c'est ma dernière paire de
lunettes j'arrête pas de les perdre
et puis c'est hyper pénible de se
trimballer tout le temps avec des
lunettes machin et tout je ne veux pas
me résoudre à m'acheter une petite
chaînette et à me le mettre autour du
cou donc j'enlève chez machin je regarde
comme ça et tout donc c'est pénible en
tout cas voilà moi j'y vais j'ai
évidemment réfléchi parce que là on a je
donne l'impression que non tu as
réfléchi j'en ai parlé autour de moi je
me suis renseigné j'en ai fait une vidéo
donc si si vous êtes là parce que vous
envisagez d'avoir recours à ce genre de
chirurgie là peut-être aller jeter un
coup d'oeil à l'autre vidéo plus
théorique
ça pourra vous donner des renseignements
en tout cas moi je me suis renseigné
avant les risques bah là encore j'en
parle dans la vidéo sur la théorie voilà
je suis bon ils sont à priori très
faible et je suis prêt à les je suis
prêt à les accepter moi je suis motivé
je suis pas je suis pas inquiet
je serai accompagné parce que peut-être
le retour on sera
complexe vu que la vue peut être un peu
voilée après l'opération il conseille
quand même de pas venir seul à un autre
truc moi personnellement j'ai arrêté de
fumer depuis plusieurs mois déjà pour
tous les types de d'opérations
globalement pas celle-là en particulier
pour tout les types de l'opérations
notamment pour ce qui concerne la
cicatrisation le tabac c'est pas ouf
donc si vous avez moyen d'arrêter ça
disons de moi avant histoire de vous
refaire une petite santé avant de vous
faire opérer bah c'est pas mal tout cas
c'est ce que conseille aussi le
chirurgien là que j'ai vu moi pour moi
c'est fait après si vous pouvez ne pas
reprendre après c'est cool aussi parce
que franchement voilà avec les économies
vous vous paierez votre opération laser
parce que je l'ai dit dans la vidéo
précédente mais on est quand même sur du
2000 3000 euros pour les deux yeux selon
la technique choisie c'est un petit un
petit budget quand même
voilà bon bah donc il me reste plus que
à faire ma dernière nuit de sommeil
réparateur
avant l'opération
et voilà comme je vous ai dit je suis
sur on se retrouve demain je vous emmène
là-bas
et ben voilà on y est c'est le c'est le
jour J c'est le grand jour
je suis prêt j'ai bien dormi j'ai bien
mangé c'est important ça de bien manger
j'ai pris une douche évidemment
j'ai fait tout comme on m'avait dit j'ai
pas mis de parfum
j'ai même rien mis j'ai pas mis de crème
sur mon visage pourtant j'aime bien
mettre de la crème sur mon visage que ma
peau respire le soleil et la santé tout
ça ouais j'ai rien mis qui risque de
d'irriter mes yeux je suis prêt j'ai mis
du déo quand même parce que on n'est pas
des bêtes
non je me sens je me sens prêt oui alors
quand même un truc assez marrant cette
nuit donc j'ai bien dormi pas de
problème mais j'ai rêvé de l'opération
alors pas si ça se passait pas mal ou
quoi juste un rêve assez chelou
d'ailleurs que je vous raconte pas parce
que c'était vraiment chelou et pas très
intéressant
et un peu gênant
mais j'en ai rêvé je me dis que en
général quand les trucs viennent nous
faire coucou la nuit pendant qu'on rêve
c'est qu'on a pas forcément tout réglé
la quand on est éveillé donc peut-être
que au fond je suis moins serein que ce
que je veux bien me l'avouer mais bon
enfin non franchement je j'ai beau j'ai
beau y réfléchir alors cette nuit j'ai
toussé aussi et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment je me suis dit [__] si je
tousse pendant l'opération parce que il
y a un high tracker sur la machine pour
bien suivre les mouvements des yeux pour
que le laser aille toujours au bon
endroit parce qu'on va on bouge toujours
un peu les yeux mais quand même si je
tousse d'un gros coup tu vois si j'ai
une quinze une quinte de tout
est-ce que ça a pas à craindre du coup
je me suis dit bon en vrai c'est à
priori c'est vraiment quelques secondes
le laser donc
il y a moyen que je me retienne de
tousser pendant quelques secondes on
peut faire ça
mais du coup j'ai eu peur de me
contracter à mort pour me retenir de
tousser et que du coup je pète voilà bon
je me dis vaut mieux péter pendant une
opération que que tousser et se
retrouver avec non non mais je rigole en
vrai je suis je suis vraiment c'est
normal
d'être un peu inquiet je sais qu'il y a
très peu de risques de complications je
sais qu'il y en a pas zéro donc voilà
peut-être que c'est le petit coup du
rêve c'est peut-être pour me dire voilà
mais en vrai non je suis je suis
tranquille j'ai tout ce qu'il faut j'ai
bien mis mes gouttes pour préparer mes
yeux jusqu'au dernier moment j'étais
hyper obéissant j'ai mes lunettes de
soleil pour la sortie j'ai mon dossier
j'ai la décharge signée j'ai évidemment
tout le matériel pour filmer tout ça et
la personne qui veut m'accompagner pour
filmer et me raccompagner chez moi et me
tenir compagnie pour pallier à mon petit
trouble de vision à la sortie
donc j'ai tout j'ai tout ce qu'il faut
juste il me reste un dernier petit truc
à faire
[Musique]
voilà bah du coup je suis presque là on
peut y aller je vous amène avec moi vous
allez assister à l'opération avec moi je
vais essayer de pas mettre des images
sales on est parti allez on est parti
on sait jamais quand même
faut toujours froid j'ai toujours les
yeux qui pleurent finalement vu que le
risque c'est d'avoir les yeux un peu sec
après peut-être pas plus mal qu'à la
base j'ai les yeux plutôt larmoyant
ok je fais demi-tour je suis allé trop
loin apparemment j'ai dépassé la
clinique sans l'avoir
ah c'est là bon à gauche on se retrouve
à l'intérieur rebonjour c'est de nouveau
la voix off je sais pas si vous oui bon
c'est toujours Julien en fait donc on
m'a refait des examens pour être sûr que
tout était toujours bon pour tout
vérifier pour être bien sûr et
franchement ça m'a arrangé qu'ils aient
envie d'être bien sûr avant de s'y
mettre et puis après bah on m'a envoyé
m'habiller et me préparer petite
surchaussures
petite sur blouse et
petite Charlotte c'est le truc sur la
tête
et puis après on m'a mis des gouttes
anesthésiantes dans les yeux je pleure
pas quand même des goûter ça fait une
drôle de sensation
drôle de sensation je sais pas si j'ai
du mal à cligner les yeux aussi c'est la
sensation des paupières qui est glisse
sur le
sur le globe
peut-être c'était juste de l'eau et
c'est complètement hystérique et puis le
grand moment est arrivé
ensuite je me suis installé et ils m'ont
préparé pour l'opération et les choses
sérieuses ont pu commencer alors à
partir de maintenant il va y avoir des
images de l'opération pas des gros plans
rien de sale pas de sens ça c'est une
pas avec le laser mais pour celles et
ceux qui supportent pas trop tout ce qui
touche aux yeux littéralement peut-être
couper l'image et garder que le son je
vais expliquer les étapes de l'opération
donc c'est bien d'avoir le son et puis
je vous préviendrai quand ce sera fini
et que vous pourrez regarder pour ça on
va utiliser un safwork quand vous
pourrez regarder je dirais
péristaltisme voilà alors donc je disais
et les choses sérieuses ont pu commencer
première étape on me met un blépharostar
un écarteur à paupières pour que mes
yeux restent bien ouverts je pensais que
j'aurais hyper envie de cligner des yeux
avec ça et ben non pas du tout
franchement ça va ensuite l'ophtalmo il
me ce qu'on appelle un anneau de succion
en gros c'est le truc qui maintient
l'oeil et qui aplatit la cornée pour que
le premier laser puisse découper un
petit volet rond dedans donc là bon bah
je sens comme une espèce de pression
c'est pas super agréable mais ça fait
pas mal quoi le truc qui peut être un
peu flippant c'est que pendant le temps
que c'est en place ce truc là bah on
voit plus rien on perd la vue mais c'est
normal donc quand on le sait ça va
ensuite le premier laser donc il découpe
le fameux petit volet le capot le truc
rond là c'est pas super agréable mais ça
dure 10 secondes donc bon
la même chose de l'autre côté et puis on
passe au deuxième laser ouais ça va très
bien
ok maintenant ça va je suis content
d'avoir que deux yeux mais
c'est supportable
alors là le second laser vous n'avez
strictement rien sentir
mais du coup j'imagine c'est ce qui
clignote au milieu là ça c'est le laser
qui va corriger ma vision comme je suis
presbyte c'est un petit peu particulier
mais on en reparlera plus tard là on m'a
remis un écarteur à paupières le
chirurgien et la soulevé le petit rond
de cornet qu'il avait découpé mais qui
est encore accroché par un petit bout et
il a rabattu sur le côté pour pouvoir
envoyer le deuxième laser donc celui qui
va corriger ma vision
c'est un claquement une odeur de brûlé
c'est parti
ça sent un peu le barbecue vous imaginez
la suite le deuxième laser dans le
deuxième œil
ça va pour vous ça va très bien
et vous ça va
très bien
moi aussi
et puis c'est tout
[Musique]
hein
non ça va très bien même pas mal
je vais vous raccompagner ok voilà donc
péristaltisme
vous pouvez regarder c'est bon c'est
fini alors du moment où je m'allonge au
moment où je me lève il s'est passé pile
12 minutes 12 minutes c'est très peu et
quelques secondes de laser et
apparemment j'ai été super
c'est vrai
voilà c'est fait je me suis fait opérer
les yeux au laser alors on va en rester
là pour aujourd'hui parce que ça a été
déjà bien dense surtout surtout pour moi
mais je vous donne rendez-vous très vite
je vais revenir vous raconter en vidéo
comment ça se passe dans les jours qui
suivent niveau douleur niveau vision etc
et puis surtout est-ce que ça a marché
et oui parce que c'est quand même ça le
plus important donc on se retrouve très
vite pour cette nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
comme d'habitude prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]